in this video we're gonna be talking
about angular current version five
points something if it's six or seven
and near-future most of this stuff is
backwards compatible you don't have to
worry about any of that but we're gonna
be talking about angular what it is what
it does and then we're also going to be
introducing you to the important parts
of it so what is angular right well
angular is one of the one of basically
two main JavaScript front-end frameworks
there's a react and there's angular
angular referring to angular 2 and above
right angularjs is typically angular 1
anyhow there's also view which is
another up-and-coming JavaScript library
framework there's a bunch of JavaScript
frameworks but there's really two main
ones that are dominating the the market
at this point in time that's angular and
react weird we talking about angular 5
currently the current iteration
oftentimes just referred to as angular
so why you saying Euler well same reason
use any framework you want to angular a
framework is supposed to in theory allow
you to write cleaner code that is more
efficient and sometimes sometimes has
better security and also already have
some resources there to to make your
life a little bit easier as well as make
your code more readable so a framework
will also gives us a lot of ability to
manipulate the Dom which is something in
vanilla JavaScript it's a little bit
harder than it needs to be and so that's
really why front-end frameworks exist so
that we can create code that is easy to
read that has enhanced functionality
that involves quicker development that
may allow us additional features as well
as security and authentication and
angular is pretty good at all that so
what are we going to be covering well
we're gonna be covering angular's major
parts angular any framework is massive
in scope and you know I just got done
taking a 25 hour angular course not too
long ago and we're gonna we're gonna
cover in this one hour so all the major
parts that you absolutely have to know
and that's going to be components those
are our reuse
parts those are reusable classes we're
gonna be covering module modules this is
where we essentially create a list of
all the parts that we want to use and
inject it into things we're going to be
covering services how do we do Ajax
calls and how do we share functions
between multiple components between our
reusable parts that's what services are
for and then we're going to be talking
about pipes how do we format and display
data in the UI without actually without
actually augmenting the data that's what
pipes are forming they're very helpful I
found myself really creating pipes left
and right now I absolutely love them and
we're gonna be talking about routing how
to this is a I need to edit this but
this is a this is not that little bullet
point is incorrect so how to actually
showcase certain things in a route so we
want to you know when our route changes
angular and all these frameworks are
called single page applications you
never actually load the page but you do
have you know routes where oh if my
route is this please display this
component please display this view
please display this item to showcase and
so we're gonna show you how to do that
in routing let's go ahead and dive right
in
[Music]
all right there's some things that we're
gonna need to install before we get
started when we want to develop an
angular application one thing is you're
gonna have Tech Center the one that I'll
be using for this video and the one that
I recommend just because I'm a big fan
of it is Visual Studio code if you go to
code division studio com download it
install it you'll be good to go another
thing that I'll be using is a git
terminal and you can go to get - SCM
comm to not only install git on your
appear but also get the git bash
terminal which you'll see in a second
one other thing that you'll need to make
sure you have installed this node as
well if you go to node.js org slash en
slash or just go to node.js org and I'm
sure they'll have your language as well
and you'll be able to down the way this
you don't need to get the current you
can just get the recommended one for
most viewers I'm not gonna walk you
through how to install that it's pretty
straightforward you download the file
you keep keep clicking next and it's
installed and last but not least we're
gonna install the angular CLI what is
the angular CLI this is the angular
command-line interface and what this
allows us to do is get a angular
environment set up and running very
quickly in a short amount of time and
pretty much every time I start a new
project I install the latest version of
angular CLI so if you want we can go
ahead and walk it through this part just
because I think it's a little bit more
so all those instructions so I'm gonna
launch my git bash terminal and if you
have git installed at this point in time
and then you right click you so you get
bash this will launch it just on the
desktop we're gonna install this
globally which means that we're gonna
have access to it anywhere in our
application and all we're gonna do here
is NPM install - gee that's that global
at angular slash CLI there you go make
that a little bit bigger for everybody
and this will take just a second so if
it's taking a minute don't don't sweat
it alright so after you get done
installing you'll see some some stuff
like this everything will be good to go
looks like at the time of this video the
angular CLI is in version 1.7 point 4
now what we need to do is wherever
gonna go and create our angular
application in my case I have a tldr
folder that I'm gonna go to you're gonna
go to that folder TLDR and launch your
get bash there we're going to be using
this command here ng new and this is
gonna allow us to create a new angular
application and all we have to do is
then name our app and I'm gonna just go
ahead and call it TL TL DR angular and
this is gonna the angular CLI is going
to automatically create a working
angular environment for us to get
started with to be pretty pretty
straightforward we'll walk through a
little bit more of what's inside the
application when this when this gets
done installing and what you need to
know about it when we get up and running
here all right so let's go ahead and
open our text our choice again I'm using
Visual Studio code what we're gonna do
is we're gonna go ahead and open that
file that just got created this folder
that just got created and we're gonna
see a ton of crap in here and a lot of
it we're not gonna worry about but I'm
gonna give you a quick rundown on what's
going on here so you'll see this TS lint
TS config this is going to be to give us
some styling suggestions as well as you
know angular is written in typescript
we're not going to talk too much about
typescript in this application I'll have
a separate TL DR video I can I'll be
doing on typescript and then you know we
have our readme file for some
information about how to run our
application and then we have our angular
CLI Jason this is some of the setup here
so if you need to import a global style
sheet or anything like that you can do
that here if you need to import a global
scripts tag you can do that here as well
you can see the name of our application
as well and then when we these are our
node modules all the installs that come
along with angular and some end-to-end
testing so a couple more things to see
so this is our global style sheet the
styles.css so if we want to apply styles
globally to our angular
and we could do it here and you don't
need to worry about that and then an
index dot HTML you'll see we have this
app root this is our index at HTML is
exactly what you would expect we have a
title here for our main homepage and
then our app root allows us to Alette
this is what's injecting the at some
point we have to inject our components
into here so that's what's going on here
don't worry too much about that for the
time being and then assets don't need to
worry about that then app ok I could
have spent a lot more time you know
talking about this but really all this
sort of stuff isn't important we have
our package JSON where this has our
installs at the time of this video it's
apparently installing five point two
point nine specifically of things in
angular just for that so you know and
our dependencies and all that sort of
stuff let's go ahead and talk a little
bit about a component and actually get
this up and running so we could see what
comes by default with the angular CLI
project alright so let's go ahead and
launch the angular the default angular
project which we've made no changes to
quite yet you'll notice that I'm
actually now in the folder the same the
root folder TLDR angular that we created
all we have to do here is put ng serve
and what this is gonna do is it's gonna
launch our development server angular
the angular CLI creates a nice little
project for us where by default if we go
to localhost 4200 we'll go here we have
a wonderful little environment this is
what it's going to look like by default
when we get started with an angular
project I have some links to CLI
documentation the angular blog etc etc
and then the tours of Heroes example now
one thing to keep in mind is the
development server is really great so
that if we made a change to our
application like so and we wanted to
change welcome to app for instance yeah
to welcome you know hello to app and we
saved it the angular CLI project that
setup automatically refreshes it so that
you know we don't have to go and click
refresh every time we save and make it
change in our application it's gonna do
that for us alright so what we're gonna
be doing for our application is we're
gonna be building a survey form and then
we're gonna have some services connected
to it but that's gonna cover everything
that I want us to talk about so before
we move forward let's actually gut out
this HTML file you'll see here that this
is just the stuff that we already looked
at this isn't gonna be helpful to us
we're going ahead and cut that out but
let's talk about how each one of these
components you'll see this component key
where this basically lets us know what
this is right and there's a definite
file filename convention that goes along
with this but this dot HTML that's gonna
be our view the dot CSS that's of course
gonna be our style sheets one thing to
keep in mind with angular style sheets
by default if we have a CSS folder or a
style sheet in our component level like
this it's actually going to only apply
even if we create a name and ID it's
only going to apply it directly to the
component here it's it's the styles for
this specific component you'll notice
suspect es file we don't need to worry
anything about this right now all this
is is some karma and jasmit unit testing
all of a separate TLDR video going over
specifically karma and jasmine on how to
get going if you're interested in
testing specifically with angular I have
my part two course we write a ton of
tests
we're building a cryptocurrency a
front-end application using a
cryptocurrency API and it dives deep
into that if you're really interested in
that so then we have our app component
in an app module we'll come back to app
module in just a second but this app
component now remember I told you this
is how we build our reusable parts
you'll see that were hat importing
component from Pat angular core all
we're doing here is importing this
dependency all right so let's talk about
this decorator here and what this
basically is this @ component so you'll
see that we have a selector a template
URL and a style URL when you're defining
a component there's three main pieces
the selector remember in our index.html
where we where are you index.html where
we have this app route this is our
selector so the selector allows us to
inject the other components into a
template into a view and then use it and
render it the template URL here is the
HTML content that's in there and now
remember we're going to be connecting
the the component logic to the template
but you know in our case we could we had
just the angular hello you know welcome
to angular in the three links right we
delete it all that and got rid of that
from the Styles URL this is an array you
can have multiple style sheets in here
if you want but this allows us to have
custom CSS for our component alright so
before moving on let's talk a little bit
about modules what they are and what
they do
modules give us the ability to at the
end of the day allow us to import a
group of items and install them into our
application basically say hey
declarations are going to take in your
components imports are gonna take in
other modules that are going to be used
and then providers are gonna take in
services and bootstrap our components
that will be automatically added when
this all launches and runs
don't worry really worry about these
three main ones here are the ones you
have to worry about for the extent of
this video and just get up and running
so declarations you have components
imports you add modules providers you
add services we don't have any services
yet but modules at the end a really are
just a way to add dependencies to your
application whether they're external or
internal that you've created to your
angular application the reason you might
use modules is not only to organize your
code better but also to sometimes as
applications get more and more complex
you may only want to load a third of
your code unless they get to the certain
route in your code and then you'll load
the other 2/3 and so your application
we're running a little bit faster things
like that so that's that's modules and
as we go and create components we'll be
jumping back in here too
some stuff so let's get started by
creating by in our first app component
here we're gonna go ahead and create a
heading and a title and we'll get
started creating our survey form one
more thing before we get started I'm
gonna actually install bootstrap this is
just gonna be for some styling and CSS
you don't really have to worry about it
too much more than that so to do that
all we have to do is make sure you're in
the your root directory and then go npm
install bootstrap it's take just a
second to install alright after it goes
ahead and installs you'll see something
like this bootstrap is currently in
version 4.0 right now and well we have
to next we just have to add the
dependency even though it's added to our
application we have to add it to either
one of two places the angular CLI JSON
we could add to the styles here I
personally like to instead just use an
import statement in our global styles
say add import and then just tilde will
essentially hit the root of the node
modules and then we'll say bootstrap
slash dist slash CSS slash bootstrap dot
min dot CSS it's gonna give us access to
bootstrap to use as we're building out
our components in all right so our
survey form is going to be about crypto
currencies mainly cuz I already have
some crypto currency guys I'm familiar
with you don't have to know anything
about crypto currencies for this
tutorial so what we're going to be doing
here is we're just going to start off by
creating a little container this is just
some bootstrap and if you're curious how
I short-handed this built into Visual
Studio code basically has a Emmet
plug-in in the background which allows
us to type div and then classes like so
with the dot or the hash tag for ID and
hit tab and then it will allow us to
when we hit tab it's going to create
that for us so we're gonna go ahead and
create this div container class then
we're gonna create a h1 here that we
just put a crypto survey in it going to
save it alright and then of course we
need to restart our server
we haven't done yet so let's go ahead
and do ng serve real quick that's gonna
launch huh
as well all right it's back up
all right rather than switching between
screens and all that sort of stuff I'm
just gonna put the screen in the bottom
left corner and every once in a while I
might pull it in for major milestones of
the video like towards the end so you'll
see here we have our crypto survey h1 if
we wanted to we could have a class Tech
Center just to Center it make it look a
little nice so nothing crazy so far now
what we want to do here is we're gonna
ask we're gonna have three parts three
inputs maybe a name a a a drop down like
an input a drop down and then a comment
so three inputs but I actually want to
create a new component to do that so and
then also include views for the first
start off what we're gonna do is we're
just gonna create the component we're
using the angular CLI all right so to
get to any other CLI to generate a
component for you all we have to do is
ng generate component and then the name
of the component in our case we're going
to call it Krypto - form and this will
automatically create the component for
us wham bam go ahead and lower this jump
back into our application and you'll see
we have this crypto form component now
that has been generated in our
application so what gets generated with
it well we get a CSS file we go to HTML
file it's just gonna have some text in
here so you can see that it displays
we're going to get this testing file
then we're gonna get our natural
component here that basically everything
said about with a constructor and ng on
and then we'll talk a little bit about
what that is and how we're gonna use
that moving forward so one other thing
that happens in our app module you'll
see here we it automatically will take
and import our crypto form component and
add it to our declarations using the
angular CLI so we don't have to worry
about that if reason the angular
but now that we have our component
created how do we add a component to
another application well it's pretty
straightforward right we saw how we did
with app component so how would crypto
form component well do it well let's
look at our selector here we have app -
Krypto - form go ahead and copy that and
we go ahead and jump right into our app
component HTML put that hit hit tab save
it and we should see the text I was in
there and we do where's this crypto form
works right where you see that there's
something there very small if you're
watching this on mobile all right very
nice let's go ahead and delete that and
now we're just going to create our form
real quick
so we'll do a div we'll make it a row
and then we'll create a div call excuse
me I'm sick why filming this so I'll
apologize so I'm just an easy um so
we'll go ahead and create a call MD -
six we'll put a label in here it'll be
it with like font - wait - bold to make
the label there and this will be for was
this whole dude name and then in here
we'll have our name and then we'll have
an input this is going to have a class
of form control all this stuff is
basically just basic HTML and a little
bit of bootstrap so it looks nice
and we're gonna give this an ID equal to
name so when we click on the label it
goes in there and we'll go ahead and
create another we'll save that real
quick so that should give us a little
label and a little form control nice
click name go in there cool it's going
to create another day of real quick and
then we'll be div call - MD - 6 another
label font - wait - bold we'll call this
4 this is going to be a drop down of
some crypto currencies and we'll just
call this cryptos
and will say favorite crypto and then
we're going to create a drop-down so
have our select tag and this will be we
can get rid of name here we don't need
that but we do need ID here for cryptos
and then we're gonna go ahead and create
an option and we're gonna iterate
through that in just a second so one
more thing that we need to create for
HTML is for that outlives will spread
that out a little bit so it looks
alright
and of course I meant to add class here
equal to form - control this whole is
just make it look nicer all right and uh
we're at it we don't need to have this
instant so narrow we'll just have a text
input div dot row if call - MD - 12 and
we can just go ahead and put a label
font - wait - bold this will be for
comments and then we'll say comments and
then we'll have a text area dot font -
wait - bold alright
Oh delete all this other crap alright
cool so basically we just see a little
bit bootstrap a little bit uh oh this is
a form control excuse me so form -
control a little bit of mr. Pelley
so we basically created a little bit of
HTML here looks clean it's nothing
nothing super crazy and then let's go
ahead and create a button I'll just you
if dot row and in here we'll have a
[Music]
we'll just making it uh doesn't matter
I'm like a button and we'll say dot BTN
dot b TN
- outline - success oh and also let's
make it let's just make it block level
button and then here we'll just say send
or something like that
alright uh it's not gonna look right if
we don't do this whistle do it so
everything's on the same page
oh cool uh and maybe we'll add a little
bit of padding to the top or margin to
the top so MT - - just a bootstrap
margin class very nice alright cool so
uh pretty basic so we've created our
component we're not using routes yet
we're not gonna worry about that but
let's actually and we haven't done any
logic in our component yet we'll come
back to that in a second but let's go
ahead and actually create a service
because we want to populate this
drop-down here with a list of crypto
currencies so how do we go in create a
service alright before we move forward
let's look at the the endpoint that
we're gonna be getting our data from
well beginning in from HTTP colon slash
slash API coin market capcom / v 1 /
ticker and if you don't have a json i
have an extension called the json format
or you can just google type Chrome
extension JSON format it'll come parse
like this and so I highly this is just
straight-up text but sometimes I'll come
back it's one long string so you can't
collapse it I really like this plug-in
it's a great one but basically what
we're gonna do is we're just going to go
ahead and pass in this name property
from the object but first we have to get
the service so that we we can actually
do the Ajax calls let's go ahead and
create our service we're gonna create it
just like how we did our component if
you remember earlier or we can do ng
generate service and what are we going
to call it well in this case I think
we're just gonna call it our crypto
service
wham-bam cool so you'll see that we have
created a crypto service it added here
now we're not gonna be talking too much
about good file structure and folder
structures there's just no time but
typically I would have my own I would
have a every one of my components would
have their own folder and a services
have its own folder model would have its
own folder pipes would have its own
folder so on and so forth
but for the sake of this video in time
we're just gonna go ahead and not worry
about that so you'll notice that when we
create a service a couple things happen
one it creates a test a test application
here for us to test the service we're
not gonna worry about that again and
then it creates our service you'll
notice here that we have this add
injectable this allows us to create a
service at the end a similar how we have
to pass in the the metadata with the act
component the @ injectable is for
services that's going on here
and you all just also notice that now oh
didn't at it that's very I thought it
was gonna add it so we have to add the
crypto service in order for us to use it
in other applications here to the
application so we're gonna import what
did we end up being crypto service
service if that isn't a bad name I don't
know what is so let's go ahead and just
drop off that last service real quick
crypto service I probably should have
named my virtual service so from that
what are we going to name it right here
just pass that in cool so now that we
have an importer we have to add it to
our ng model though importing here
without adding it to the ng model does
nothing services get added to the
providers now our applications will have
access to our service so how do we make
an AJAX call from our service though
because that's our that's our end goal
right that's what we're trying to
accomplish okay so as of angular five
the HTTP module slightly changed and so
we're gonna import in our service the
HTTP client and
it's gonna be from at angular slash
common slash HTTP now one thing to be
able to use this is we actually have to
import the HTTP module in our app module
here so that we have access to this
essentially alright so in our component
in our excuse me in our module we're
gonna import the HTTP client module from
the same place that we just did a moment
ago for HTTP client now this is gonna be
at angular / comment / HTTP and then now
that we've imported it we have to go to
our imports here and just let it know
that we plan on using it and adding it
to our imports so now that we've done
that we'll have the ability to actually
use the HTTP client now when you're
doing a service in the constructor if
you're a constructor basically all it
really all you really need to know about
this if you're not familiar with more
object-oriented programming is a
constructor essentially when we create
our crypto service these are the
properties that get created along with
it that it that are these are the the
dependencies that get added to it and so
we're gonna create that dependency and
we're just create we can just put HTTP
we're not gonna put anything as public
or private because I don't want this to
confuse anybody so HTTP of type HTTP
client now that we've done that whenever
you actually go and use the crypto
service we'll have the ability to go and
and use the HTTP client modules so how
do we go about actually doing that Ajax
hull it's pretty straightforward we're
gonna create a function in here called
get Kryptos and all we want to do here
is return this dot HTTP dot get and then
remember that route I was just telling
you about a second ago we're gonna take
this route
we're gonna pass this in like so and
then we're going to say what's the issue
it's gonna miss here HTTP just don't
exist on type of crypto service yes it
does I think this is just a little bit
of the module issue here sometimes when
you add new modules without restarting
your server you get some some little
warnings we'll worry about fixing those
warnings later on so what we're going to
return here is what's called answerable
by default it returns a promise so the
way that we convert our promise to a
observable is we just use the concat
method and what we're gonna get back
from here is a response I'm go ahead and
wrap that and what we want to do is take
that response and we want to take that
response and we want to return it back
as an observable in JSON form so now
that we've done that this will allow us
that's what crypto rock cr1 yes okay
crypto so there we go
to subscribe to that observable in our
component and then get that data let's
go ahead and see what that's going to
look like all right so how do we add
this service chart component well so
exactly how we added HTTP to our service
is now when we jump into our crypto form
component TS in our constructor knowing
we are going to first we have to import
that service so we're gonna import the
crypto service from dot dot slash crypto
service and then we're gonna add it as a
dependency and in our case we're just
gonna call it crypto service and then of
type crypto service now by default we
want it to actually fire off and that's
what this ng on and
it is essentially when the component
loads it will then fire off whatever
code is within here on an it comes from
at angular core and you can just put
implement on knit as well as this
function name ng on in it to make sure
that the code gets fired off so all
we're going to do is say this dot crypto
service dot get up and of course make
sure you spell crypto service or your
intellisense will not work it and get
does what's going on here
no I spelt alright okay cool get
dose and then what we want to do is we
want to subscribe to those Kryptos and
this is gonna pass back some data and
all we want to do here good time beam
just make sure we set everything up just
want to go ahead and console dot log
that data save it and everything should
work although this is giving me an error
alright so it looks like it's having
some issues detecting our alright
dependencies what we're going to do is
we're actually gonna close our server
and then we're going to rebuild it the
reason for this is sometimes when you
add new add new dependencies to modules
create new components it angular
sometimes doesn't know they exist and I
think that's what's happening here so
HTTP does not exist on crypto service ok
so my mistake here is we have to
actually jump back in here and put this
public property on apparently for
dependencies and this will allow us to
essentially have access to our crypto
service within it otherwise I think it's
assuming it's private or it's assuming
that it's it's so I didn't want to do
any public or private aspects of our
application here but it seems when we do
dependency injection we have to actually
add that and so let's jump back into
crypto service and do the same thing
public in this case really only means
that hey other applications can use it
even the user can call this if they want
to and so now we'll have access to our
application and concat map it also made
a little mistake here good cat map you
don't have to do this in the application
anymore it used to have to in the old
one but well will have here is just this
get call go clean up the code a little
bit no big deal and then jump back into
our crypto forum component which now
you'll notice and I'll go ahead and pull
this down for this you'll notice in the
shot here we get our hundred kryptos and
we have access to the whole thing that's
because the reason for that can cat map
is when we made the change from angular
HTTP to angular common HTTP they convert
it from promised observable for you and
so that's why we're doing it and we no
longer have to do that so that's why
that function doesn't exist all right
the next thing that we're going to do is
we have to actually store this data
right does no good for us to use it in
our template if we can't store it and
iterate through it so what we're gonna
do is we're just create a variable here
and we're just going to call this crypto
array and what this is is is a property
of our component and crypto array is
probably a really bad name so let's just
I call this top 100 Kryptos and we'll
just initialize it here and then in our
data instead of just console logging it
will say this dot top 100 crypto s-- is
equal to the data in a production level
application we would have some models
and we'd be creating some classes and
maybe an interface we're not worried
about that right now we're just trying
to get the basics down so we create this
property and this top 100 Kryptos now
that we have this well we can actually
use it in our application so let's jump
into our crypto form component and what
we want the whole reason we set that up
was for this drop down to actually
populate with values and the way that we
can iterate through an array if we use
this structural directive here called ng
4 which will let us do that and all we
have to do is say we'll say let
Krypto now that is our element that
we're going to be iterating through of
top-100 Kryptos that's our array and
then using string interpolation with
these curly braces we just say crypto
dot name that dot name of course comes
from the the application that the that
we were looking at and you'll see here
we have our 100 kryptos in order of I
believe marketshare and why we're at it
let's just had add an option here so
that it's not gonna select the very
first value but now we've set up our
service with a with Ajax college do a
get call everything's working well save
that and bam so we have access to the
top 100 Kryptos very cool but how do we
actually store the data and pass data
and you know how do we how do we do that
well we're gonna use a something called
NG model so NG model allows us to create
essentially place a two-way binding so
that we can change a value in the
controller in our component and we can
change values in our template or our
view here and so do that now let's go
ahead and jump into our form component
we'll just define an object real quick
and we'll just call this crypto survey
and this is gonna be equal to an object
and we're gonna say name and by default
we'll set it to an empty string and
again you'd probably be doing this in
class and then we'll say favorite crypto
we'll set that to an empty string and
then we'll do comments and we'll set
that to an empty string so we have
another property like we have with our
top-100 cryptos from earlier but now we
want to be able to target this directly
and change the values so how do we how
do we modify our HTML to do that well on
our input here we can use a ng model
and assign it and what we're gonna sign
it to is essentially exactly that which
I forgot what the hell the name I just
defined it was crypto survey what an
appropriate name dot name so we're gonna
save that and you see we get this big
scary wall of text why did we get that
well uh one cuz I first forgot to put
name but we should get it I believe we
should get another wall of text okay now
we get a less scary was still scary wall
touch can't by the end you meiosis is a
known property of input all that means
is that we actually have to jump into
our app module and we have to import the
forints module right so they're assuming
that you're doing some sort of form if
you using andrew model you're probably
working with forms and they want you to
go ahead and import the forms module and
add it to your application and that's
gonna be from at angular slash forms
very cool take our forms module throw it
in there save it and that should solve
our issue moving forward and now we can
go ahead and and everything works and
you'll notice that if we wanted for
instance a set name by default to Dylan
we could change it in our application
and you'll see it loads with Dylan and
if we were to change this it would
affect this as well and one way that
we'll we'll show that is when we do our
submission so let's go ahead and delete
that and we'll just go and have ng
models to the rest of the application
like so so add it on the select and I
called that what did I call that
favorite crypto and just gonna copy that
one more time and then comments I can
remember comments where are you text
area
alright comments
cool so now we've added we've now
connected in both directions our
application here but where do this we
want this form to send us somewhere
right really what we want this to do is
we wanted to do it we want it when we
click this to have it call and send some
data somewhere in our case we're not
going to send anywhere we're just gonna
pretend like we are but how would we do
that well we can have this click event
here that then calls a function that's
called Sen form and does some stuff in
our case we're gonna go ahead and create
a function called send form and all it's
going to do is console.log top-100
Kryptos cool and we can see that just
the two-way binding is working just fine
so that's like that we go ahead and put
Dylan remember everything starting off
empty will do Bitcoin and we'll do like
okay then I don't know what to put in
the center for and cool when we send the
form oh I didn't mean top 100 Chris I
meant crypto survey excuse me but you
did see that it logged out the top 100
Kryptos for that wasn't long ago far so
Dylan Bitcoin duh
send form and you'll see in our
application now that we've actually
modified the way that this is gonna look
50 favourite crypto name oh look we have
a bug in our code favorite crypto did
not set its value the reason for it is
we didn't set our drop down value which
is why you do these checks which is
pretty straightforward this is just some
HTML really at the end of the day and
all we have to do here is jump back to
option instead of every value being that
all we want value to be and we'll just
wrap this when we wrap this like this
what this essentially is doing is done
doing property binding where essentially
if we wanted to pass in a boolean that
would be like that and not it wouldn't
be the string true and it's the same
thing for crypto dot name this will
allow the name to be put in there not
specifically the string crypto dot name
and then you'll see now we go ahead and
put something here go ahead and put
something here select bitcoins submit
our form and bam now we have Bitcoin in
there as we wanted before alright so
next what we're gonna do is we're gonna
go ahead and create routing and see how
we can set up our routes in angular this
is a you know pretty common property of
our that item topic and single page
applications is a single page because we
essentially create these mock routes
we're only display certain things if our
route or our URL here is in fact a
certain path we're not actually
reloading the page we're just changing
what's in our view and so what's gonna
happen is from name favorite crypto
comments in stone form when we click the
send form we want it to then go and
change the route we're still gonna have
our crypto survey heading there because
our router outlet we're gonna add this
as our as our router as our route as our
view that changes based on what our
route is so how do we do that well first
thing we're going to do real quick is go
ahead and create a new component go
ahead and go to your application like so
I should have had this open my apologies
TLDR TLDR - angular get bash and ng
generate component and in our case we're
gonna just call it form
- submitted and that's going to generate
a new component for our application cool
here's our component has all the same
stuff that we already talked about we're
not gonna worry too much about that
right now instead what we're gonna do is
we're gonna comment out this app crypto
farm form and you'll notice that it it's
it goes away right as we would expect
right because we don't have that anymore
so what do we want to do well we need to
do some setup well if you haven't
noticed by now angular works off a lot
of different dependencies and it has the
set of a lot of you know these ng
modules allow us to set up and say what
dependencies we're going to use and what
part of the library we want to use well
we're going to want to import
the router module so that we can
actually use the routes at angular slash
router like so all right up next what
we're gonna do is we're gonna go ahead
and create some routes like here I'm
just going to create a constant variable
called routes and we're gonna set this
equal to an array of objects these are
really just going to be our routes that
we're going to apply in in a second so
you'll see here we're gonna have an
object there's going to be a path which
is a string an empty string is going to
be our default path right our home page
if you will and then we're gonna have
this component which is going to take in
what we what component we want in our
router outlet which is essentially a tag
this is where we want to inject the our
view where we want that to be so in our
case we have our crypto form component
we just defined so we're gonna say look
when we're on the home page define
define this there and when we're on this
other route in our case we're just going
to call it submitted we want the
component to be our form submitted
component I apologize for the bad naming
convention I'm kind of making up this
tutorial as we go along but we can talk
about clean code in a separate video and
good naming conventions and things like
that so we have form submitted component
now the way that we add our routes and
able to use it well as we all know we
have to add our module to imports and
then we're gonna have this dot for
routes for route here and if you see and
then we're going to pass in our routes
so this for route essentially adds our
application on the rule of all you have
to really know is this is so set up to
do routes that's really all you have to
know for what we're trying to get going
and our for routes not for routes and so
now that we've done that the one last
thing that we have to do is in
we just have to create our router -
outlet tag and save it like so and
you'll notice that our app crypto form
component is now here and we can go
ahead and delete this comment right
because we are on the index page and if
we go anywhere else you know it's not
going to know what is what that is and
we're gonna get in here there's a couple
different ways that we can solve this
one we create a for or for component but
we don't need to worry about that right
now that's beyond the scope of this
course but in our remember we created
another route which is just slash
submitted and now you can see our form
submitted works our form submitted
component is there and we're dynamically
changing the routes so that it goes and
works accordingly so how do we how do we
just link to this and pass it how do we
create our routes to go and send to it
well it's just an anchor tag at the end
of the day really so if we go to our
crypto form component we can go to right
here we're not going to do anything with
this send form component we'll just
create a router link on our crypto form
template and we'll just say now they're
linked and what do we want it to equal
in this case we just want to equal to
submitted and bam it jumps between
everything we want we can throw this
router link on anything that can be
clicked essentially gravity link can
also take in an array of values so if
you're gonna have different values now
this would work exactly the same just
something to keep in mind so if we click
send form it's going to work the same
that way if you have parameters or IDs
or you have multiple thing thinks you
can concatenate that but it can take in
a string or it can take in an array
alright while we're at it let's just go
into our form component and just add
some text that may
since something like you know I'll just
make this an h1 it'll make this like an
h3 and we'll have the Tech Center class
and we'll just put some something like
thank you thank you for your input
exclamation point we're not gonna really
worry about too much of making this app
look too good but that's that's that's
one thing that I can that we can do to
get started all right so let's jump back
into our crypto forum component and
we're going to jump into the HTML we're
into just first off we're going to
display what a pipe is one of the common
pipes that you can use and so a pipe
just as a reminder is something that you
are going to use to edit data or to to
essentially filter how you see data and
what it what it looks like and a good
example that is a date pipe so let's
create a variable here I'll just call it
today's date we'll set this equal to a
new date oops
new date there we go and we'll jump into
our crypto form component I'm just right
at uh you know let's jump back here real
quick and then we'll create a new div
here and in here I'll have a just put a
little hh5 that is today's date again
we're not trying to make this look the
best it's mainly about illustrating an
idea
so today's date today's date area like
oh so there's this very long string
Eastern Daylight Time all that that's
not very good what we can use though is
some built in pipes in angular to
actually go and filter this so that we
can get in the form we want without
having to manually change it so the date
pipe we're looking at that documentation
right now you can see that it comes with
several formats
you can use as an example short is
equivalent to month day year year our
minute minute and then time zone all
that sort of stuff and then you have
these are all predefined but you can see
there's a lot of different examples and
it goes on and on and there's a lot of
documentation some other pipes in here
to keep in mind they have the number
pipe which is allows us to you know do
decimal places on our numbers there is
the to lower case and to upper case pipe
all that sort of stuff there's also a
slice pipe there anyhow there's a bunch
of pipes and you can write your own
we'll go ahead and showcase how to write
our own real quick after we use the date
pipe so we should I believe we already
have the common module imported here but
all we need to do to use the date pipe
you know knows we're using these and
primarily in our HTML so if we parse by
date you'll see we get the default one
but now we get this very nice added very
nicely filtered default value now if we
wanted to do our own custom one we have
this colon that comes so the pipe as you
might imagine is denoted by this pipe
and if we wanted to add custom ones we
could do it with a colon and this
essentially tells us hey we're about
that in an optional parameter to our
pipe here like so and we've a passed in
short remember we have the short we
could also pass in I believe mm is month
month minute Arden was that minute that
might be a minute yes minute I think mmm
is month which is the fourth month for
our useful just passing short but that's
how you pass it in optional parameters
now let's go ahead and create our own
custom pipe alright we're gonna make a
very simple pipe what we're gonna do
real quick is just create a a drop down
here that has a boolean value of true or
boolean value of false say hey do you
like crypto or do you believe in crypto
so we'll just do a create a little div
real quick
make that a row a little div dot call -
MD - 12 and a label dot font - wait -
bold and love crypto I'm like that and
was this ask a question it'll be true or
false
do you love crypto and ideally you
probably wouldn't use a select tag for
this but we're going to select love
crypto and then in here we'll have
option value true and then we'll have
true here for now and then we'll also
have option false and then we'll have
false here for now as well and what
we're gonna do is we're gonna write a
simple pipe that says if it's a true
value if it's if the value is true go
ahead and change it to yes output is yes
if the value is false go ahead and
output it to false alright so let's
start by creating a new pipe how do we
create a price at this point you
probably guess ng generate pipe and
we're just gonna call this bull bull yes
actually it's called yes yes no it's
gonna create a new pipe for us jump into
back into our component for submitted
and then you'll see we have our test
file and then we have our actual pipe
alright so let's go over what's going on
in our pipe here so you'll see we're
importing two things for our pipe we
have pipe pipe transform this is our
decorator and remember how we did slash
date that's what this name is for in our
case is gonna be yes no and then of
course we're exporting yes no pipe and
we're implementing pipe transform what
is the transform property coming from
pipe all that is is essentially our
logic hey when we call this pipe on a
value what do we do with it and so here
we can go ahead
take care of all this sort of stuff not
trying to introduce any time script as
much as we can in this in this
introduction video so what we want to
happen here they say hey if value
meaning if it's true return yes else we
don't need a else right because it's a
return statement it's not gonna hit this
unless the sauce else go ahead and
return no and so now we've essentially
written our first pipe let's go ahead
and save this other file and excuse me
for having that and what we're gonna
need to do now is we're gonna actually
need to import that pipe in our modules
so that we can use it elsewhere
all right let's go ahead and fix our we
just have this very nasty little input
here and so let's go ahead and fix that
by just adding this class form control
which is a game it's just a bootstrap
class form - control which will just
make it a little bit more pretty cool so
what we need to do is jump into our app
module and import that pipe oh look it's
already been imported for us you'll
notice that pipes go in declarations as
well just ask components - let's go
ahead and close some of this and so what
we can do here is we'll just do some
string input interpolation we'll put the
string true here and then we'll pipe it
with yes/no and then we'll do the same
thing what's false
so BAM so you'll see our values here are
actually oh excuse me so the reason that
this is returning yes and yes it's not
because our pipe is locked because I
made a mistake here so remember we're
expecting a boolean value and when their
strings they are going to always be true
because it's going to be so you'll see
yes and no and the value here is true
and false and so that's a very basic
pipe pipes are really powerful
like I write I use a pipe I've just
called keys pipe which essentially if I
have an object I don't know what the
names and the keys are gonna be I'll do
the keys and I can have access to all
the values in it and it's really dynamic
in that way something I use quite
frequently so when you're creating pipes
and you're really wait how do you want
to think about pipes is when you're
creating something that's gonna affect
how it gets rendered in the UI you might
want to think about using a pipe rather
than writing some custom logic in the
component and that way you can reuse it
any of the other components as well all
right so I think we're gonna stop there
for this quick rundown of angular
there's a lot of other things we can
talk about in angular animations we
could talk about um sending data from
one component to another and from a
parent to a child child to a parent we
can talk about how to you know inject
services and other services and we can
talk about testing there's a the list
can go on and on angular is very very
long so if you're interested in diving a
little bit more deeper deeper in an if'
to angular projects part one is a
introduction projects about three and a
half hours of content where we're going
to be building a personal portfolio
we're getting introduced to a lot new
concepts as well expand on what we have
and then part two is a cryptocurrency
project where it's about eight hours of
content or six hours of content I forget
what it is it's a it's about twice the
size of the original project and this
goes into even more advanced details so
if you enjoyed this I appreciate you
guys watching the video don't forget to
comment like
subscribe sure I hope it gave you maybe
a little bit of a head start a jump
start to get going with angular 5 and
angular thank you for watching the video
don't forget comments Milo I'm trying to
do an outro here comment like subscribe
share support me on patreon hit that
notification bell all that good stuff
I'll see ya and Milo we'll see you next
time
bye guys